imagina que estás viendo una película
muy muy larga en el cine y tengo ya es
un paquete entero de palomitas de maíz y
tu refresco gigante y de repente tienes
que orinar para empeorar las cosas la
película que estás viendo trata sobre un
grupo de personas que viaja en un
crucero y golpea una verg así que hay un
montón de agua en esa película y te
empiezas a inquietar porque ahora tienes
que levantarte para ir al sanitario pero
eso te pone a pensar cómo funcionan mis
riñones cómo es que puedo hacer toda
esta orina de la que me tengo que
deshacer bueno en los siguientes vídeos
hablaremos de cómo funcionan los riñones
esta vez daremos un resumen rápido antes
de profundizar más en los detalles
como puedes ver tenemos dos riñones que
se encuentran justo aquí alrededor de
nuestro ombligo tienen aproximadamente
el tamaño de un puño y están cerca de la
espalda no están realmente adelante los
riñones reciben sangre del corazón que
se encuentra aquí y que también tiene el
tamaño de un puño el corazón bombea
sangre a todo el cuerpo un poco a los
brazos un poco al cerebro y también
tenemos una rama que baja las piernas
puedes ver en esta imagen de los riñones
que tienen un pequeño vaso por aquí por
donde les llega la sangre al corazón
ambos riñones filtran la sangre y
liberan la orina que es solo una
colección de desechos y la orina va a
pasar un rato nuestra vejiga que se
sitúa justo aquí hasta que es el tiempo
propicio para ir al baño
este es el resumen general pero vamos a
entrar en más detalles sobre lo que
hacen los riñones vamos a dibujar una
caja por aquí que represente cómo
trabajan los riñones e intentaremos que
el resumen sea lo más simplista posible
y en otros vídeos profundizaremos más en
los detalles como mencionamos en cada
uno de nuestros riñones entra un vaso de
sangre oxigenada o una arteria y las
arterias guardan todas las cosas de
nuestra sangre incluyen nutrientes entre
los nutrientes tenemos electrolitos como
los iones de sodio proteínas aminoácidos
e incluso la glucosa que forman los
carbohidratos todo lo que nuestro cuerpo
usa como bloques de construcción o cosas
que ayudan a otras estructuras para el
funcionamiento de nuestro cuerpo
además de los nutrientes en nuestra
sangre arterial también tenemos oxígeno
y productos de desecho que nuestro
cuerpo ha producido a través de la
respiración celular y todos los demás
procesos a los que se somete
estos desechos incluyen la urea y otros
componentes tóxicos que ya no
necesitamos y no queremos acumular
también pueden incluir electrolitos
extra como el sodio que ya no
necesitamos ya que si conservamos mucho
cloruro de sodio que es sal
terminaríamos con una presión sanguínea
alta así que nuestros riñones también
nos ayudan a mantener una presión
sanguínea estable como veremos en otros
vídeos lo que queremos resaltar es que
el exceso de estos nutrientes se
convierte en productos de desecho
entonces nuestros riñones nos ayudan a
no acumular demasiado de este buen
material todo esto es lo que entra por
la arteria al riñón como recordaremos
cuando tenemos una arteria que llega a
un órgano oa una parte de nuestro cuerpo
también tenemos una vena que recoge la
sangre y la regresa al corazón
entonces el trabajo de los riñones es
recolectar y mantener los nutrientes que
están en nuestra sangre arterial cuando
lo regresemos a la vena así que se
mantienen los nutrientes y los riñones
como todo órgano en el cuerpo necesitan
oxígeno así que parte del oxígeno que
pasa por los riñones se regresar a la
vena y otra parte lo usarán ellos para
mantener su tejido así que del otro lado
en la vena tenemos oxígeno pero en menor
cantidad
por eso escribiré un pequeño o dos como
sabemos hay mucho menos oxígeno en la
sangre de nuestras venas que en la
sangre de nuestras arterias finalmente
nuestros riñones toman todos los
desechos que vienen a la sangre de
nuestras arterias y evitan que terminen
en la sangre que va a las venas al
recolectar estos productos de desecho
los riñones producen orina
ahora bien seguramente podemos notar que
a esta imagen le hace falta algo que
conecta la arteria con la vena bueno lo
que pasa aquí es parte de lo que hace el
riñón tan especial es la respuesta al
como como es que los riñones pueden
hacer esto cómo es que los riñones nos
ayudan a mantener en el cuerpo los
nutrientes mientras se deshacen de los
desechos en la orina bueno el riñón es
especial ya que tiene dos lechos
capilares seguramente has escuchado
anteriormente que es un capilar un lecho
capilar es algo que conecta una arteria
y una vena en los capilares el oxígeno
puede fluir hacia afuera y los
nutrientes pueden fluir hacia adentro
así que dibujaré un lecho capilar por
aquí que conecta la arteria y la vena y
otro por acá que conecta estas dos
estos trabajan en conjunto para entregar
oxígeno al tejido del riñón y al mismo
tiempo recolectar estos nutrientes así
la avena lleva los nutrientes a otras
partes del cuerpo que los necesite y
estos lechos capilares tienen dos
nombres elegantes al primero se le
conoce como vasos rectos que
principalmente le da oxígeno a los
riñones el otro conjunto de capilares se
le conoce como capilares peri tubulares
y estos son los encargados de recolectar
los nutrientes que los riñones filtrarán
hablaremos con mayor detalle de todo
este proceso en los siguientes vídeos